- I am blown away by how fearlessly
you embraced this transformation.
- Right, exactly, I feel like radiant,
and beautiful, and sexy, and confident.
I had it in me but you all brought
it out and I really appreciate it.
I just feel like I had
pretty much given up
on kind, genuine people,
like really I did,
because everyone that I met
I felt like they pitied me,
and they looked down on me, and you know
they expected me to be someone else,
more black, less white,
more gay, less gay.
So I basically just accepted
that the real world sucks
and family doesn't exist,
unconditional love doesn't exist,
but you all just showed me that.
It's beautiful and sexy
to care for yourself.
- Yeah it is.
- You know what I mean?
And it's like cute and
confident to just be black,
and be gay, and be a
woman, and what that is,
is me, and I'm always that.
- Yes.
- Bobby, oh my goodness.
I felt connected to you from the beginning
and it's inspiring for
someone with my background,
our background, because it means that,
like the sky is the limit,
and you're just actually
a really amazing person.
- Thank you for letting
me in and allowing me
to be a part of your story, I love you.
- You now know your identity.
You know who you are.
- Honestly, you are a huge
black role model for me.
I look up to you so much.
And to meet you I was really scared.
I was intimidated, 'cause I thought that,
like everyone else who looked like me,
you were just gonna be
like, oh she's not enough.
She's weird, and you were so
warm to me, and encouraging.
You are exactly what I wanna
be in terms of a black person.
You are yourself and that's beautiful.
It took me my whole life to realize that
and it is just so impactful to me.
- I can't say how much I
love you and appreciate you.
- [Jess] Thank you so much.
- [Karamo] Now, none of
us don't wanna leave you.
Like, can we get invited to this party?
- Surprise.
- This is us.
- Yay.
- Let's hug it out.
- Yeah let's hug it out.
- [Group] Hug it out.
- [Anthony] Have fun tonight.
- I will.
- You're gonna be great, just be calm
- Miss you, have fun.
- [Jess] Bye.